so there are a number of other
monetization methods out there and I
brought a list of them just because
there's a huge number i want to make
sure that I'm not leaving important ones
out I left this to the end because the
performance is really going to vary app
to app where some of the other
monetization methods that we went over
are a little bit more common so firstly
there are surveys and this is where
you're offering players in-game rewards
generally for branded surveys what's
your favorite soft drink things like
that there are also real world rewards
so this is the most popular case for
this would be if somebody maybe gets to
level 4 in whatever your game is and
they get a reward for free kleenexes or
something like that that they can then
redeem at a real-world location or order
to their house there's also affiliate or
e-commerce so I've seen with a lot of
cases particularly games and apps that
are extremely well-designed or arted
that sometimes they'll sell prints of
popular characters or other elements
directly to players and some cases
they'll direct them to other app stores
and things like that they can purchase
this and in a lot of cases you can get
affiliate revenue which is a percentage
of the users purchase even if they're
not purchasing whatever you're directing
them to which is key so if you send them
to the app store and within 24 hours
they make a purchase of another game
you'll get a very small percentage of
that if you have a wide enough audience
base this adds up which is really cool
there are also things like notification
ads little pop-up notifications text ads
there are things such as offer walls
that were for I guess like the beginning
of the App Store extremely popular and
that's where you're offering players the
ability again to get in-game rewards if
they either download and install other
games or if they complete offers for
subscriptions to magazines or Netflix or
something like that which is extremely
popular finally there are app walls
which is like a hybrid
of offer wall and banner ad unit where
you display a list of different games or
apps perhaps some of them you own some
of them you don't own and players can
pick and choose what they want to
download there's a whole range here and
really depends on what converts best was
within your game